♪ -Musical genre challenge ♪
-All right, now here's how
it works, okay?
We're gonna take turns hitting
this button here,
which activates
the Random Genre Generator.
Or Random Jenre Jenerator.
[ Laughter ]
It will land on
one random song title
and one random musical genre.
Whoever's turn it is has to sing
that song in that style.
-Okay.
-All right?
I will start us off.
Here we go. You ready?
One, two, three.
"Shape of You."
Ska.
[ Laughter ]
I kind of know --
I know "Shape of You."
I know a little ska.
How fast is ska?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I'm in love
with the shape of you ♪
♪ Push and pull
like a magnet too ♪
♪ My heart is falling too ♪
♪ I'm in love with your body ♪
♪ Oh, I, oh, I, oh, I, oh, I ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a little -- I don't
know what I was doing there.
All right.
I'll let you go ahead.
Ariana, it's your turn.
Go ahead.
-Okay.
-All right.
It is "Humble."
-Goth rock.
Like, goth rock -- like 2003
Evanescence goth rock?
-Yeah.
What does that sound like, yeah?
-Like, hot topic shopping goth?
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, how does that sound?
Yeah.
♪ -Oh ♪
♪ Right stroke put Lil baby
in a spiral ♪
♪ Soprano C, we like to keep it
on a high note ♪
♪ It's levels to it ♪
♪ You and I know, bitch,
sit down ♪
♪ Be humble ♪
♪ Sit down ♪
♪ Oh, sit down ♪
♪ Be humble ♪
♪ Sit down ♪
♪ Oh, sit down ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?! Stop it.
♪ -Sit down ♪
-Wow. Wow!
That's exactly what it was.
All right.
I don't know why,
but I'm going again.
Okay. Here we go.
That was fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah," the Usher song. "Yeah."
Yeah. Boop boop.
In a country jam?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
♪ I was up in the club
with my homies trying to ♪
No. Stop, stop.
Can we do like --
[ Laughter ]
You know what? Maybe like a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we do like a Johnny Cash --
I feel like a Johnny Cash, like
a slower, like a recent,
like a later Johnny Cash.
Like a Rick Rubin/Johnny Cash,
like "Hurt."
Like really slow.
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, okay. Yeah.
All right, yeah. Yeah, okay.
Here we go.
♪♪
♪ I was up in the club
with my homies ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Trying to get a little V.I. ♪
♪ Keep it down on the low key ♪
♪ And I'm like, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the best I could do.
That's the best I can do. Sorry.
All right.
-That was so good. Okay.
-Ariana, take us home.
-"God's Plan."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"God's plan."
-'90s diva.
So, like, poppy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"God's plan," Drake. '90s diva.
♪♪
-[ Vocalizes ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I hold back sometimes ♪
♪ I don't, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I feel good sometimes ♪
♪ I finessed down Weston Road ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, oh, oh ♪
♪ Might go down a G.O.D. ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ God's plan, yeah ♪
♪ God's plan ♪
♪ God's plan, yay ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
That is it for
Musical Genre Challenge.
Ariana Grande!
-Jimmy Fallon!
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
We're talking to Ariana
after the break.
Stick around.
[ Both vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Ooh ♪